لا شيء هنا سوى الركام وقد صار ما كان
بالامس منزلا تعيش فيه عائله الاسير
الفلسطيني اسام بني فضل في قريه عقربه
جنوبي مدينه نابلس كومه من الحجاره دفنت
تحتها ذكريات يتجاوز عمرها 20 عاما نشاهد
هذا المنزل وقد تعرض للتفجير على يد قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت القريه
وسط ظلام الليل الدامس وقد صار اثرا بعد
عين القوات الاسرائيليه اقتحمت القريه من
محاور عده وسط اطلاق كثيف لقنابل الغاز
المسيل للدموع ما ادى الى اصابه شبان
فلسطينيين بالاختناق
تتهم السلطات الاسرائيليه الاسير بني فضل
بتنفيذ عمليه ادت الى مقتل اسرائيليين
اثنين في بلده حواره قبل عده اشهر ويؤكد
حجم الدمار في المنزل الذي كانت تسكنه
عائله الاسير استمرار سياسه العقاب
الجماعي بحق الفلسطينيين كما تقول
العائله لم تترك القوات الاسرائيليه في
هذا المنزل زاويه صالحه للعيش وتقول عائله
الاسير انها ممنوعه ايضا من اعاده ترميمه
وبث الحياه فيه من جديد محمد خيري الجزيره
عقربه جنوبي مدين nables